in short it appears nothing at least not
for the moment following an afternoon of
meetings here that the President had
with his national security team no
decision has been made on how to respond
in Syria but president Trump will speak
tonight with both UK prime minister
Theresa May and the French president
Emmanuel macron about possible ways
forward in his public appearances today
President Trump was focused on tax cuts
jobs and trade our massive tax cuts that
are growing paychecks all over our
country that creating jobs and expanding
the American dream just like we said
would happen that's the way it's
happened
but behind the scenes urgent meetings
today with defense secretary James
Madison Airmen general Joe Dunford and
other members of his national security
team deciding how to respond to last
weekend suspected chemical weapons
attack in Syria
having a number of meetings today we'll
see what happens this meeting is over
but we're looking very very seriously
very closely of that whole situation and
see what happens a senior administration
official tells FOX News the White House
is confident chemical weapons were used
against civilians in Douma French
president Emmanuel macron said he has
quote proof that it was chemical weapons
though he did not elaborate on what the
proof was the British cabinet today
defied public opinion polls showing just
22% of Britain's support military action
agreeing to partner with the US and a
statement saying cabinet agreed it was
vital that the use of chemical weapons
did not go unchallenged president Trump
has blamed Russia for not raining in
Bashar al-assad saying Vladimir Putin is
at least partly responsible for the
chemical attack it's too bad that the
world puts us in a position like that
you know as I said this morning we've
done a great job with Isis we have just
absolutely decimated Isis but now we
have to make some further decisions so
they'll be made fairly soon after first
talking tough vowing to shoot down any
American missiles fired at Syria Russia
today was seeking de-escalation a
spokeswoman for the Russian Foreign
Ministry urging dialogue with the u.s.
we're living in 2018 we have all sort of
communication including Twitter and we
can resolve all the questions like that
just picking up the phone just sending
messages and I think that this is the
case which which should be resolved
through the communication but not
through force the president has been
using Twitter to send messages warning
Russia yesterday that missiles will be
coming nice and new and smart that
prompted criticism from some members of
Congress that President Trump was
telegraphing his military moves
president Trump fired back on Twitter
today
never said when an attack on Syria would
take place could be very soon or not so
soon at all on Capitol Hill today
warnings that the president may need to
ask Congress to approve a military
strike if he goes any farther than last
year strike on a Syrian airfield
anything beyond that he will need a new
authorization for the use of military
force in prepared testimony for his
confirmation hearing today Secretary of
State nominee Mike Pompeo said the
failed state of Syria poses a mounting
threat to human rights national security
and regional stability and it deserves
an increasingly severe response and he
told the Foreign Relations Committee
President Trump has the authority to
strike not seeking the approval of
Congress yes I believe the president has
the domestic authority to do that I
don't think I don't think that has been
disputed by Republicans or Democrats
throughout an extended period of time
with no decision by the White House
tonight on what to do about military
action whether to use it at all and a UN
chemical weapons team headed to Syria to
investigate the Duma attack the window
of opportunity for an imminent strike
may be quickly closing the president
Trump likes to keep his
off balance and guessing and the White
House still insists that all options
remain on the table